[Music]
black holes
we're riveted by their destructive power
black holes are dangerous
black holes are hazards black holes are
not friendly for their environments
there's just no good ends to anything
that falls into a black hole perhaps one
of the most frightening objects in the
universe
but what exactly are these scary objects
black holes are created when you get
enough matter in a small region of space
this happens when a massive star dies
and collapses in on itself
a supernova a black hole is the ultimate
consequence of gravity is an object that
has so much mass crushed into such a
small space that it's escape velocity
becomes greater than the speed of light
they are a one-way street
you go in nothing escapes not even light
but two black holes really deserve their
bad rap in some ways I think we setup
black holes to be more villains than
they actually are black holes suffer a
bit of a PR problem I think they're a
lot more menacing in science fiction and
popular media than they really are
[Music]
there are trillions of galaxies in the
known universe and most of them have a
supermassive black hole at their center
these monsters are millions of times the
mass of our Sun their immense gravity
can send stars flying their instrumental
in choreographing the dance of stars in
their vicinity supermassive black holes
shoot out torrents of lethal radiation
and violent cosmic winds and gobble up
anything that comes close now
scientists are beginning to realize
these cosmic giants may also have a
creative side most people think of black
holes as being like giant vacuum
cleaners in space and basically
everything falls into them but that's
that's not actually the case they're
better thought of as the engines of
cosmic change although black holes are
the end states of stars they can
actually influence the formation of
stars as well in a bunch of different
ways a galaxy's job is to make stars but
uncontrolled star growth isn't healthy
too many stars can drain a galaxy's gas
supply black holes are very important it
appears that galaxy evolution is tied to
black hole evolution we don't know
exactly how yet but the marriage appears
certain one idea is that supermassive
black holes
act as cosmic control mechanisms black
holes can act like a thermostat in your
house if your house gets too hot the
thermostat will kick on the
air-conditioner and if it gets too cold
it'll kick on the heater black holes do
the same things for galaxy's
supermassive black holes regulate star
formation by pulling gas in and shooting
it back out into the galaxy when these
black holes are consuming matter they're
drawing matter into themselves but
they're also spewing stuff out basically
black holes eat like little babies very
sloppily so a lot of it but the eath
comes flying back out again the stars
the planets but most often may join
clouds of gas the black hole drags gas
and dust into an accretion disk around
it this disk spins faster and faster
magnetic energy builds up
with the accretion disk swirling around
the black hole there are also magnetic
fields that are going on the material is
moving so rapidly that the magnetic
field sort of winds up coils up and
forms the vortex like a tornado
astronomers call them Jets
[Music]
these Jets propagate outward like
freight trains plowing through the
galaxy over hundreds and thousands of
light-years these are like death rays
the Jets disrupt the star-forming gas
clouds limiting excess star formation in
the main body of the galaxy but in the
very outer reaches of the galaxy they
can spark star birth things are more
gentle out there you're not as close to
the energetic heart so stars planets and
life can form out there partially
because of the material that the black
hole has moved out there so black holes
can have outsized influence on the
regions that they inhabit right around
them they can prevent the formation of
stars whereas on very very large scales
they can actually instigate the
formation of stars 2018 black holes hit
the front page
scientists discovered black holes
gobbling up gas so fast that they seemed
to be outgrowing their host galaxies it
naturally makes the question come up how
big can a black hole get now we have the
answer they can reach size triple-xl
becoming ultra massive black holes
[Music]
ultra massive black holes are so cool
because it's just mind boggling that
black holes so large can exist ultra
massive black holes are very rare and
typically have masses of more than 10
billion times the mass of the Sun 10
billion solar masses that's a 10
followed by nine zeros Ultra massive
black holes are real beasts the black
hole at the center of our galaxy is 4
million solar masses imagine black holes
that are 2,500 times bigger that's what
we're talking about here
[Music]
an ultra massive black hole this big
would be as wide as the solar system and
weigh as much as all the stars in the
Milky Way
they're inside galaxies that aren't a
whole lot bigger that really surprised
the hell out of everybody and in 2018
scientists discover a twenty billion
solar mass ultra massive black hole
growing faster than any other black hole
this ravenous behemoth devours the mass
of our Sun every two days
these big black holes are really good at
gobbling up other things to literally
eat anything they're monsters of the
universe this kind of for a shish eating
can have devastating consequences it
blasts so much energy and turbulence
into the galaxy that stars no longer
form and the bigger the blackhole the
faster that galaxy dies the primary
thing these ultra massive black holes do
to galaxies is they shut down all star
formation and so in that sense they kind
of kill galaxies and sold these things
could even wipe out their host galaxies
ultra massive black holes are a problem
for scientists - they might be the
fastest eaters but that doesn't explain
how they got some large
with these ultra massive black holes
these black holes that are tens of
billions of times more massive than our
Sun you can't just grow them from the
slow accretion of gas over time there's
just not enough gas and there's just not
enough time
it gives us a new mystery to solve how
do you make black holes that are just
that big there's not a clear answer so
far as to how these ultra massive black
holes were formed people wonder if
there's some other mechanism by which
you could make black holes a mechanism
so violent it also throws supermassive
black holes clean out of galaxies